[Music]
give a new show coming out for the
people what's it like going from playing
one girl boss oh yeah do another girl
bye oh well especially when you surround
yourself with more girl voices that is
Jasmine yeah Joe come here but when you
got this call that they want you guys to
star in this Shonda Rhimes show what's
your reaction yes yes yeah we're up for
the challenge
how did Shonda approach you guys about
this she auditioned our buddy also I
play a lawyer and like I didn't think
anyone was gonna be buying me as a
lawyer so I needed to audition you know
just so that I know I know that they
know that I can do it you know what I
mean
and then we got to read together at my
last callback and that way I was super
fun and it seems like you guys have
already been bonding if you're showing
up to Halloween parties together I've
been like learning the legal jargon I
literally go to work and I'm like okay
today today I've got my closing argument
speech and you just see me like pacing
back and forth I'm paramount law it's
just like reciting words that I don't
even freaking under so came here then
it's unusual we always look a little bit
crazy
yeah work is you have to get it right
like I can't change a single word what
I'm saying it's wrong I'll just add
stuff too because I think it sounds
better right and they're like stop but
it doesn't make sense we're gonna make
ours rise come on we don't wanna be that
strict how far into the filming process
are you guys right now already on a
break girlfriend no we're two episodes
it
and we go to New York first I'm 7a yeah
you can tell us about the pilot I think
that it celebrates you know female
friendships oh yeah and having it on my
back yeah another girl's back which is
really important to me she writes for
the female for sure
so it's good to be on her side
[Music]